well Moody's a very respected firm that you know evaluates company said that you all are in trouble and I think sort of that Oh commercial when EF Hutton speaks people listen you know for a lot of people when he speaks Moody's and S&P s do not have a good track record prediction if anyone's a rearview more a predictor its Moody's and S&P so I should say to be precise where does an SP are really good at predicting steady-state behavior of a company but that's like that's that's pretty easy it's like if you're a car going down a dead straight road and you look in the rearview mirror that's about the same as looking about the front windscreen alright so that doesn't get to you people did think though it's just that they're fundamentally not good at predicting the future in a rapidly changing environment that I I thought they would think that they are